hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen you look
so good with that thank you you know I
can't thought if you were in the black
one but I got the kitty unicorn thing
there yeah it's super cute I think it
works better today we are watching
legend what do you know about this movie
I know that Tim Curry isn't it yeah and
Tom Cruise I started to watch the first
10 minutes of it though was gorgeous I
got so goddamn bored I turned it off I
should give a chance I you know I don't
know people talked about this movie I
know something about a soundtrack like
there's a version where it's a different
soundtrack maybe not by tangerine dream
I don't know banned cuz it's really
Scott there's like five director cuts
but yeah but we're gonna try and watch
the original theatrical version that's
the one that was on the big screen and
everything so I figure we should watch
that I didn't know that it was really
Scott who I loved so mmm I'm excited to
see what it looks like
Tim Curry's makeup on the cover look
yeah like I've seen those scenes like
you know and that that's amazing so I
think it's a no reason it's like I
should watch it's just just for the
honor of Tim Curry because I love Tim
Curry Wow Doug it's a week later and
you're still wearing the same weird
right crazy that you did I just live in
this this used to be a white shirt um
you're not gonna snap with me it doesn't
change your shirt
[Music]
I'm so glad I turned that off the first
time I saw it man damn it that was
so boring twice was that boring how do
you make something look so beautiful so
amazing in the makeup I mean who like
read this script it was like just take
all the money make the most beautiful
gorgeous thing ever with this dialogue
in BC's 30 million dollars for this
budget out of this world and it was I
have never cared less about characters
in my life it's only an hour and a half
and it just felt like three if you felt
like I watched like all the Hobbit movie
it was very like Dark Crystal and that
it looked beautiful was just boring as
hell yeah like with Dark Crystal like
suddenly there's this resurgence of
people being like yeah that movies great
like I just assume everybody loved that
movie I'm like hey everybody I knew did
not like it growing up and I'm wonder if
this is like the opposite cuz a lot of
people I knew like yeah that was good
that was good and now I'm just hearing
more and more yeah there's really
nothing much to that movie is there it's
just visually it's stunning this is one
of those movies where like the
environment is so grand clearly the
writer director just had this
environment like oh it's gonna feel huge
and look huge but what they're talking
about or doing doesn't matter in the
slightest for sure like the characters
are just so forgettable they introduce
the little shirtless dude I don't care
about you at all it's so fun cuz
everyone's clearly throwing the wrong
everyone talks like this it everyone's
going to write everyone Tom Cruise has
got the Tom Cruise basa
so derpy yeah I mean but he's put his
all into it you can just tell and it's
just like man I don't care I just don't
care it was so incredible like going to
his lair and like seeing his giant
castle and all these like weird
creatures and his makeup and everything
like yeah like how would you even feel
your face I mean like but he just looks
like now I just walk around like this
every day just my Friday thing I mean
it's like he just looks so comfortable
with it typical Tuesday night Jim Carrey
except when he was doing the fight scene
at the end then for some reason he just
looked like this
a whole time that almost like you were
some bass like someone else was fighting
and they just had a Tim Curry mask on
huh that could be it but it was clear
yeah I don't blame you at all Tim man I
couldn't do 10 minutes and then make
them you did a whole movie impressive
the script is just it leaves a lot to be
desired it's just generic fantasy stuff
you know Pixies now it's Bill Doyle but
a dog and it's like just everybody talks
like that nobody's a person yeah the
only time I listen to anybody was when
Tim Curry talked and again that's just
the power of Tim Curry everything is
dubbed which again you get because
there's obviously a fan blowing all
the time
but like half the people you swear are
not the people that voice that like the
caretaker for Lilly whoever that was
like there's a scene where they're like
frozen there's a guy in the background
too it's like oh did she have an uncle -
or father whatever we don't know but
like she's got a very sweet auntie but
she talks exactly like this and it's
like that's not the voice at all that's
not you know everybody sounds like this
it's like just one woman doing like all
these boys yes I use the original voices
of beaches different voices and he made
me just blew the budget so big it's like
okay everyone's done by one person I
guess right oh except for Tom Cruise who
had like such an awkward he was still
really finding his feet I feel like Tom
Cruise didn't find his acting feet and
so like pretty recently like he was real
derpy and real awkward which I you know
a little endearing but first of all they
didn't let him wear pants and his legs
were white they were way too many
upskirt shots okay also was it Jennifer
Connelly I don't know if the box says
Tom Cruise but I think Jennifer Connelly
at least did face doubles at time we'll
never know so much glitter so much man
we just got done watching Lost Boys - if
like you know the glitter blood in it
this is just this seems to be the day of
glitter I guess for whatever reason
granted I guess I expected more in this
but they're really crying glitter
there's more - a concert and this
bill Lincoln there everyone is taped on
like it's caked the snow is just glitter
no it's just what do you think Tom
Cruise does his off-time in this movie
we think she does in her off time like
they just sir Frawley can look happy
like that's it like I have no idea what
their interests are their hobbies are
anything in little things like that make
them feel human yes yes you know nothing
about them and so you just don't care
about them at all
another thing I have been through seven
Chicago winters and you do not frolic in
a snowstorm in that dress you just don't
do it yeah it's very frozen logic like
you just sort of walk around like Tom
Cruise literally has his legs open and
he's just like you know Oh where's Lily
okay dude get warmed also when he gets
armor they're like here take this
mystical armor and it's the same it's
clock sounds like a mini dress yeah
which is somehow looks do you think like
Oh get some armor on it but look for a
dignified note flick to even sillier
maybe it had pants but he was just like
no I refused to wear pants also the
unicorn horns are about as I think ours
are staying more straight yeah then than
the ones on the actual horses wait okay
I can't complain because everything
looks amazing and the money that must
have been thrown into this but I just so
wasn't invested in everything else that
I notice stuff like that right I want to
like stuff like this where it's like it
is slow-moving it is big it is epic but
it's like I just don't like or care
about anybody yeah I just couldn't get
into it I can totally see other people
kind of getting sucked into like the
music and the slow-mo and the
environment and stuff buddy I just
didn't give a about the people I
was saying like if I would have seen
this as a kid I would have really dug
like her costumes and the unicorns and I
wasn't even like a big pony person but
like it was just so beautiful I feel
like I would have really dug it as a kid
but it was just so hard to sit there now
you know one of the reasons I think we
like to in Korean this I just realized
he at least has motivation he at least
has like purpose like you know I want
this is what I'm used to this is my what
I want to bring this bag he has like the
one the only line I remember from this
which even though I'm trying to remember
to get it right
yeah it dreams of the youth are regrets
of the maturity of mature something like
that and I was just like I mean really
we remember a line from Abby's very
pessimistic but it's a good line and
it's like I can't remember one other
word not even like a word
oh my favorite part of the movie is when
that women Green Goblin comes up and
calls Tom Cruise a juicy boy yeah she
looked fat juicy vine that's another one
I was kind of like you know kid her and
Tim Curry just have a movie together
like the red and green make it a
Christmas movie or we have the snow i
watch that yeah I would watch the
out of that every Christmas confusing
costumes like why is she in a beautiful
dress and he said in like this weird
ratty rags mini dress who even is she we
don't even know like who they are are
they like peasants are they just frolic
kurz next to me cameras never seen is
this just doing the directors good no no
what are we watching next Reservoir Dogs
oh I really need some Tarantino after
that yeah that's like his first film I
think I'm so excited yeah Tarantino this
is like the one that start all the
Tarantino cliches yeah I just need
talking dialogue good dialogue and
characters yeah man maybe you will hate
it can't see myself yeah just like yeah
all right well let's get to it
thank you for watching bye coin flip
[Music]
[Applause]
you